morning time in Seattle just finished
shooting a were that hot dog episode
here figure since we're already here are
you ready to go home yeah we're in the
northwest we gotta eat salmon he has no
choice we're doing it good morning guys
your mom never waking up that way no on
this special last minute addition of
worth it we're going to eat at three
amazing salmon places in Seattle
Washington at three drastically
different price points to find out which
one is the most worth it at its price
can be great great day yeah what makes a
good salmon helps old lady Salmons
across the road areas their groceries
home for them losses I don't know if
salmon eat the floss there cause like
darling their mouths first stop Emerald
City
fish and chips it's hard to find good
cheap salmon if you catch a fish free so
what's the problem
teach a man to fish yadda yadda yadda
free salmon today we're in Seattle at
Emerald City fish and chips I'm Steve
Allen I'm the owner
/ operator everything we're gonna be
trying the two piece of salmon and chips
costs 825 and you get chips which are
fries you get coleslaw and get tartar
sauce with Oh charter sauce what you
recommend on that or definitely
definitely we make our own target sauce
here in this awesome spicy version how'd
you get started in fish and chips like
why that specifically my family's
originally from Louisiana so our
uniqueness is the Louisiana Flair the
Cajun style flavors to fill your palate
but not too overbearing to where you
don't taste the fish when we get the
fish we cut it bad or a month we use a
corn flour with our seasonings from
theirs drop it in the grease it's all
good yeah yeah you're glad you're in
Seattle right now aren't you aren't you
all right all right okay I mean you're
the tartar sauce with fries right now
though yeah that's what I'm craving
I think we might have to bring this
tartar sauce to the other restaurants we
produce today oh look at that color
that's gorgeous majestic that's that
wild Alaskan salmon he was talking about
I'm swimming to my mouth I'm just gonna
eat my mmm what the fish that was
incredible the batter is so thin so you
can still get so much fish in there yeah
the fishing and hiding talked about the
seasoning it's got a kick in it but it's
not overpowering the flavor that's it
I've already torn through one cup of
tartar sauce tartar sauce I've always
been a little skeptical when people talk
about source of where fish comes from
and how it relates to its quality here
it's just like so clear leaping off the
plate you know get his color in your
life once I'm Adam I'm closer to the
friend
[Music]
super-good right so we met a guy
dominaing Kyle he's been ordering this
sanitation ships for five years now
halfway through that he discovered
smoked salmon chowder the best chowder
anything we have to get it so we didn't
come there to get it home again you
won't regret it I promise
well hello how's it going sir smoking I
love it no perfect first yeah for
Seattle
place too we just had some salmon
chowder just has some salmon chips
Wow look at this tree look at that tree
Wow so the people owe majesty
I think like this scenery right now made
that salmon chowder so much better Sam
in fact that's like a person I'm gonna
theming for Halloween next year we're
now on our way to the second summons
spots what's gonna be special about this
grilled salmon cool I'm James Somerville
on the Executive Chef here at Ivers
salmon house here in Seattle we're
actually gonna start off with an
appetizer which in-house alder smoked
salmon belly will serve that on crostini
with a little bit of herb cream cheese
and some watermelon radish and then
we're gonna prepare our seasonal
preparation of Alaskan wild king salmon
all of our salmon here at the salmon
house are wild stock they are cut in
Alaska or the Northwest area we'd like
to feature some of the first runs of all
the salmon and fresh salmon has a very
good fat content that way its moist it
melts in your mouth and has a great
flavor on the outside and what's unique
about alder wood alder wood is something
to get traditional to the northwest and
something that imparts that sweet smoky
flavor to the seafood we're here to
enhance the flavor of the fish not
overpower it
what is the seasonal preparation we have
a preserved lemon fennel beurre blanc
sauce with a little black truffle
drizzle over the top and then fresh
horseradish that's grated over the top
of that let's drink the wine first
napkin yourself first please
yeah that was donk staunch I'm sure
using that word right first that all
their smoked salmon crostini with an
herb bread a 10-point that is a fatty
piece of salmon I've ever had I think
this is an honest chunk of fish but it
has this beautiful alder smooth flavor
there it is in all its glory the alder
wood grilled wild king salmon from
Alaska black truffle drizzle can tell
you so much mmm with a drizzle you know
a drizzle is great because you only need
a little bit of it I don't think we can
cheers this so mental Cheers that was so
buttery
so melty so delightful that's what you
know Sam is done right it was flaking
off I feel like the word flaky has been
ruined by people who are habitually late
for things really let's bring flaky back
to the fish Adam it's very good right
get in here this is the way I always
want salmon to be me perfectly tender in
the center smoke and fish nothing else
sitting next to your friends even alone
in the woods forever I actually think I
liked the smoked salmon again more than
the actual salmon that's happened at
both places now can I just say that
Seattle is knocking my socks off and I
hate that you brought me here who took
you here for your first time in Seattle
that's right ready for a wild caught
salmon oh don't uh no turtle time
that's pretty good fact so a salmon
could give you a high-five I think it's
more impressive that came into hurdle
over you wow that looks like a piece of
poop so now where are we going
one fish two fish last fish here we go
we're going to aqua my El Gaucho aqua by
elegant is that a kind of cologne aqua
by El Gaucho Oh
hi I'm Wesley head I'm an executive chef
here at aqua bail Gaucho welcome to
Seattle
what do you mean serving us today we
have some fresh wild Alaskan king salmon
simple prevalence of chanterelles and a
lavender beurre blanc you're in the
Pacific Northwest we have some of the
best seafood around but we also have
some really cool mushrooms chanterelles
and salmon are kind of best friends
forever I think oh yeah we just got this
guy in you can always tell their hello
noise to other fresh that I would be
cloudy if it's not king is the king all
the nice marbling in there king salmon
has the highest fat content omega-3
fatty acids it's good for you fat
there's a series of pin bones right here
there's 32 bones in each side so I'll
just be pulling out each phone like this
now I'm gonna season my fish clarified
butter a little gotcha season it's just
salt garlic paprika over the onions
throw it on the grill we're waiting till
kind of gets a nice caramelization like
a nice brown line one side then we'll
just kind of a quarter turn it like that
you get those nice diamond marks on it
starting to get a little bit that white
coming out of the side there for us it's
about sourcing the best quality
ingredients fresh never before been
frozen so that's a little rare to
mid-rare they're about perfect I just
played it up and then just some fried
leeks fun I pressed us about the quality
and the best eating experience for a
guest
I love how they've gone on and we've
spent progressively more money the
salmon has gotten progressively simpler
now it's just grilled with a light layer
of sauce underneath but then topped with
some stuff some stuff we got a
Chardonnay
here's the Seattle that's good wine nice
and crisp lovely
but whitey try we start with the UH
mushroom yeah I want to try the
mushrooms yeah delicious and a treat in
themselves they get their mushroom from
the guy in a mushroom show who comes by
when he pleases with lots of mushrooms
it's not truffle its shan-dro
because we don't use cheers for this
never do I prefer mushrooms like this
then truffles you ready for this animal
it's the most sexual who do we got some
lavender in there ready this stuff lemon
just dripping on the table
[Music]
anymore right now
you
I didn't think that fish could be
succulent but that's what this fish is I
can like taste the salmon when you eat
it isn't that weird stop tasting through
my mouth so much better than the middle
steak the middle fish that we got today
funny that you slipped there it's at
stake because this is so much like a
perfectly cooked steak not only do I
have a view of the water a view of them
now in this this is us sounding like I
mean this part is hard to look at but
like everything around it is incredible
I can look up here and there's a mirror
and I see all of us usually a man by now
but this is good
I'm glad you dragged me along yeah I'm
so done which salmon was the most worth
it at its given price one here's the
deal there's no question that the best
salmon I ate today came from aqua was it
worth it for 56 dollars that being said
it's all about ml city I mean you could
go there any day of the year and get
that awesome chowder my boss is the kind
of place I would go right before a
football game they got good deals on
salmon you hang out 25 bucks for lunch
but I think I'm gonna go a roll
even though I didn't even plan for that
to be in the video that's how they had
me what gets eaten by bears in the
rivers salmon du-de du-de du-de du are
you okay
hit me with another salmon fact doesn't
matter how good it is you're drunk
on Omega from alpha to Omega 3s we've
had all the salmon Seattle has to offer
oh yes